[Music]
[Applause]
Ralph Samson's going to be honored at
the hall of fame series Charlotte event
next week on November 10th it's buil uh
built as the night to honor Ralph Samson
and uh he'll receive his Hall of Fame
jacket during the presentation his Alma
moer Virginia plays Florida that night
tickets available at H
series.com what does that mean to do you
when somebody says Hall of Famer
Ralph ah you know it's um especially
with the Nate Smith Hall of Fame and the
college and UVA whatever but it's very
special because you're in a class of
certain characters as you know um that
played the game on a high
level um you know it's a a great honor
for me family um
friends um this this game against
Florida and UVA will be special because
they had a new job soon and didn't get
to go to the Hall of Fame this year do
to travel and family and stuff like that
but I'll get my new jacket and I'll wear
it proudly so it's special for me and my
family and just to be there in the Hall
of Fame and what it means I think to
sports to be any any Hall of Fame is
very special best player you played
against was who myself well you didn't
play against you you you have to play
against yourself I tell everybody tells
me all the time okay you know in that
era you had to think about I come out of
Virginia and you know I stayed for four
years etc etc etc but I wasn't ready to
play against Moses Malone when I was in
high school artist Gilmore Kareem Al
jjar you know Robert Paris I mean all
the big boys thought they were much
stronger much wiser and they love to
fight back in those days as you know so
I had to play against them and get ready
but you know I tell everybody the
hardest and toughest meanest person I
play against was Maurice
Lucas uh big L with and and he was the
sweetest guy you know at off the court I
got to know him after the F but every
time I played him he would come to
Center Court and he would punched me in
my chest before the jump ball
started I like L come on man here we go
again and we had a fight when in the um
and we played the Lakers on the Western
Conference Championship and like man
come on just don't why you going hit me
tonight already so he already started
before the game start he said well I
can't catch you I can't jump as high as
you can so I just got to beat you up I'm
like okay whatever but he he was the
toughest man I I've ever played against
and the strongest with artist
Gilmore yeah uh people don't realize how
big artist was how strong he was I mean
there's a couple of guys they're just
built differently in the NBA uh Rick
Mahorn was was a I mean when he set a
pick it hurt uh it definitely hurt Mark
Eaton is one of the biggest men I mean
even Yao Ming when Shaq stands next to
Yao Ming you realize how big Yao Ming is
yep I mean sh small man you know just
but but you're right artist is the
strongest human I've ever met and if you
ever shake his hand he tries to break
your hand before you even get it done
I've seen him in games picked up kingan
with his left hand and pick him straight
up off the ground with one hand and move
him anywhere he wanted him to go uh and
you know he it's the strongest person
that I think ever played in the game and
you know Rick Mahorn played well but he
knew what he could do he couldn't jump
couldn't run fast but he could beat you
up right and that's the way he played I
was wondering about with Victor W bayama
because when I do look at him I do see
you but I wonder if you were coming up
today you wouldn't have stayed four
years at Virginia I'm guessing and you
would have gone to the NBA but do you
think that you could have been used the
same way given what today's game because
you played for Bill Fitch Bill Fitch is
saying get down on the blocks but in
today's NBA would you have had that
Talent you know skill set to be able to
do
that God bless Bill F because you know
seven Footers back then Couldn't Shoot
threes yeah I me you had to be close to
the basket so I would have loved to play
in today's game because you know I you
know I got tired of being double team
triple team and the post even from high
school to college and to get loose and
dribble so that's why I learned to
dribble I got chared getting double tap
I couldn't get the ball so only way I
could get it was rebound and take it to
court myself and so I was able to do
that but today's game would have been
very very fun to play in shooting threes
dribbling you know and and even posting
up with guys that were smaller than me
uh I can take it to the post as well so
I would have been probably I think
pretty good in today's game for sure
what do you see with w bayama and what
concerns
you I mean he has great talent um I
think he has a a high motor I watched
him play the other night with against
Kevin Durand and the Phoenix Sun where
they end up winning 115 113
and it was an amazing game to watch him
play he only had 18 points but you know
I tell everybody NBA is very smart it's
the right or wrong reason he's with Greg
papovich and he's one of the best
coaches out there in the history of the
game down with Tim Duncan and David
Robinson but you go have the out players
running but we'll see what happens uh
over the course of period of time
obviously my concerns would
be his body but I think and I watched
him some vide tapes I watch him doing
some Instagram stuff where he stretches
he has great flexibility you know when I
came out and in NBA they didn't have any
weight rooms in any gyms I was first
went to board a weight room to the
Houston Rockets to the NBA arena and now
s spth has a $500 million PR for ceiling
you know time to exchange right so the
diet is different workouts different
although I was pretty good at what I did
but I had to cook my own food and
prepare everything which is fine he has
that to his luxury but the the body has
to fill out he's still Young's you know
he's still a young man and the knees and
the ankles after 82 games is going to be
we'll see where after the first year but
my my my concern would be that he plays
against a smaller quicker guy and he's
twis and turns and twisted his knee or
ligament or joints and and and that
could hurt so I think he's got to get
stronger physically uh but the game is
is phenomenal I love his game but the
difference between putting on weight and
building strength what's more what's
more important he doesn't have to put on
any weight he's just got to get stronger
and you see his arms he has arms he his
body is swed it's is coming but he
doesn't have to put on bulk right we had
to put on bulk and and and play the post
and the body you know I was 250 pounds
at my highest FL I came in at 225 230
but I put on strength muscle and weight
and sometimes that's not a a good
antidote for playing in the NBA but I
think think he'll put on just some
strength some pure strength and then be
able to keep his flexibility yoga and
all stuff he's doing I see you doing
online and he will be a phenomenal
player no question about Ralph played in
the NBA Finals 1986 I was at the uh
Boston Garden when you guys were playing
in the NBA Finals I was covering that
you probably don't remember me but I I
was there Ralph just letting you know
what do you
remember what basket were you under
that's the question
I I didn't have good seats you know I I
was up in the rafters there what do you
remember most about playing against the
Celtics oh I mean playing against the
Lakers was fun and and went in on the
shot to get us there but everybody you
know always wanted to play against the
Lakers or the Celtics I mean you know
you play in that era because they were
so good you want to play and compete and
beat them so going to Boston was fun um
We R A very good high coming from the
Lakers to home and having all being
celebrated to Boston but we weren quite
ready for the Boston you know Fanatics
you know you go there and from people
from the taxi cab drivers to the hotel
bus boys to the maids to everybody there
with the Boston green right so you have
to be prepared for that mentally and
then you know we get we get beat up a
couple game then we come back in and
then I have the the nice fight you know
in Houston because I wanted to win you
know a good first quarter but I was
having conversation with u Cedric
Maxwell hit the radio show a year or two
ago whatever it was and when I go to
Boston and they like hang Ralph kill
Ralph for you know having a five minut
fight with j ceing and Danny H uh they
they had a a poster or a I guess they
made out SS in hungry and Effigy over to
the Boston side at at that point in time
and it was crazy and the police made him
take it down but the thing biggest thing
I remember not just to plan against
Larry Larry was very sh Larry could play
and he would he would deadly we would
have Robert Reed go to the game early
try to beat Larry to the arena and you
never could beat him you never could be
he would be there working out before
after you know he couldn't jump you know
he couldn't run fast but he was smarter
to whip so R re would try to go beat him
to the arena he never did he never did
and so we think okay Rob just stop
trying because he gonna kill you tonight
anyway right
but that the fun that was the fun part
funay and then so the other piece of
that bill Fitz when we you know we knew
we going to lose he made all of us get
off the court he took a time out all the
starters got off the court into the
locker room because he knew that the
Boston fan was going to swarm the court
and something would happen so you know
we knew that so it was fun it was fun to
play in that era I mean it was it was it
was u a good time for me good to talk to
you again have fun on November 10th when
uh it's the night to honor Ralph Samson
it'll be Virginia playing Florida thank
you Ralph good to talk to you again
always good to talk to you take care and
see you soon that's Ralph Samson number
one overall picked by the rockets in the
1983 draft and a rookie of the year he
was also three-time college basketball
player of the year